if you don't wake up by 5 a.m every day  you're gonna be poor if you don't make  your bed every day you're going to be  poor i have somehow managed to make a  million dollars and not  i have not made my bed and i have  somehow still managed to make money and  that sounds crazy making your bed  actually has nothing to do with making  money because it doesn't mean you're  selling more stuff doesn't mean more  people are finding out about your stuff  it just means you took a sheet and you  put it on the top which later you're  gonna take back down and get back into i  think rather than obsessing about things  that don't matter you should focus on  the few things that do and do those that  one drives me [ __ ] bananas